brandon theo rest of the crew what's
going on it's your boy clay from ohio
uh i got a kingdom stinging for you i
just went and dropped my buck off at the
old uh taxidermy to get it done you know
and uh
i start coming down the hill realize i'm
going the wrong way
so i'm like all right i'll turn around
so i got to turn around and snowy here
in ohio
i get stuck in the man's driveway
screwed
by myself so i'm trying to push it out
i'm hot i'm flustered
i'm pissed off either way this nice
gentleman pulls up
i'm standing on the corner like a toot
like a prostitute as theo would say
and uh he's like you need some help
of course i do man can't you see that
i'm pushing my vehicle
and uh yeah so the dude jumps out of the
car
loki looks like joe exotic from tiger
king but hey i'm not judging i'm in a
tough spot
so either way the man pulls me out we're
good to go
i'm glad he didn't ask me to come over
anything like that that'd be weird but
either way
king or sting it helping people on the
side of the road
would you stop or wouldn't you stop gang
gang is the entire audience
going to or coming back from rehab
yeah they're all field fans this is
every archetype of person i was in rehab
with
what the [ __ ] they're like king in the
stinger helping ladies cross the road
yes or no i mean i'm like i don't know
man
i don't i don't have any skills to help
people on the side of the road i don't
drive a pickup truck what do you want me
to do
it's all so dizzy helping people these
days
is it a setup i've seen too many first
forty eights i love this guy
i think it's somebody's trying to [ __ ]
him he's like i'm glad that guy didn't
try to [ __ ] me
he's like that could have been awkward
yeah it could have been weird you know
i'm just on the side of the road looking
[ __ ] pretty damn good
in my [ __ ] uh weird farmer shirt and
my hoodie
and my backwards hat and you know
thinking about why i [ __ ] got fired
from perkins last week
it's like a middle american pie right
now i know perkins stuff yeah he's like
i thought i
think you worked at perkins you worked
at first place it was my first job but
dude
gives you pie no matter what you order
you order pancakes the morning you get a
free pie it's like
nice wow they've gone out of business
like i think dude that's what i'd go on
the road i would just eat at perkins
early in the day just go to bed for like
five hours
and then wake up and like didn't know
where i was i'm like what and i'm like i
have a show in an hour
in a lemon meringue pie yeah just eating
[ __ ] french silk pie
of all the chain diners i i like i'm
proud of perkins
is there shonies out here shoni says
great strawberry yeah yeah
uh no and cocos
uh these sound higher end what about you
you're not helping anyone on the street
no no no uh it's i've just seen if
ah man if it's like a dude's dude and
like his car is [ __ ] up and it's like
we're in the middle of nowhere i help
him out
but if it's like off sunset it's too
dicey man
like [ __ ] triple a dude especially if
i'm with my kids i'm not stopping man
again i've seen way too much cold cases
in the first 48 yeah too much i know how
this ends
but i'm not gonna assume everybody's
trying to [ __ ] me like this guy right
this guy's a little out of this
yeah take it easy bubba and i think
there's part of him that wanted to the
guy wanted
he's like yeah i didn't ask you to come
over that was weird i i wouldn't have
done it but i just would have
appreciated you the ask you know
i wanted to see what i was made of i uh
the other day on new year's eve day i
went to the bank
and it was closed uh u.s bank
and so find this picture there was this
old couple there they didn't speak like
great english they were russian and uh
they were like oh super bummed out like
she looked like she was gonna cry
because it was cold i was like
i'm going to the other one like on
larchmont or something uh you guys want
to come with me and they're like oh yes
they were all excited and then
that one was closed we ended up being in
the car for like an hour did they rob
you uh no they were just a really nice
old russian couple who lived in ohio for
a while lisa and gary they were they
were
really nice people um i actually have a
picture of us
but so i came in it's a cute picture let
me see
uh i mean
obviously king helping people oh wow
there's lisa and gary what are you what
are you doing with them uh we went to
the bank
and why uh i don't know they really
needed to deposit a check we also have
an idiot accountant who can't do direct
deposits for some reason really
i don't know it's a nice chance you did
a nice thing uh yeah uh
you did a nice thing did you guys do you
give them a ride back how'd they get
back yeah
i gave him a ride that's nice i would
never do that uh but yeah uh
i i trust trust them especially
sometimes i see an elderly person
struggling and i stare at them
tim king stings it yeah i sting them
yeah i don't trust anybody so sting yeah
sorry clay
[Music]